Right now, at this very moment, you're
lying to yourself. Don't worry, I'm not
psychic. I just know that every human
brain tells roughly 200 lies per day.
Think about this morning. You looked at
your phone to check one thing quickly.
30 minutes later, you're deep in
someone's vacation photos from 2019.
Your brain just lied to you three times
since I started talking. When I said
you're lying to yourself, your brain
went, "Well, maybe sometimes, but not as
much as other people." That's lie number
one. Here's what's wild. If I hooked you
up to a brain scanner right now, I could
watch you lying to yourself in real
time. Your brain has two systems. One
knows the truth. One creates stories you
can live with. Want to catch yourself?
Watch the full video to learn the mirror
technique that exposes your lies
instantly.